one question an amazing lineup of CEOs
Founders and experts this is marketing
for the now
[Music]
thank you so much
Gary
nine days we're on the countdown to vcon
yes vcon is very close I'm very excited
about that and I'm very excited about
this subject matter uh so you know what
I'm excited about what's that we're
turning three today
three years old for marketing now some
years
289 interviews we've had that's quite a
few I would say 144 countries 100 000
viewers each time not bad
not bad but let's go let's go let's go
guess what our first interview is with
Melissa Hobley who's the CMO of Tinder
and she actually she's coming to vcon
she knows all about Indianapolis she's
going to teach us all the things in
Indianapolis but today we're going to
talk to her about the power of community
she's an expert in love She's gonna
throw down some insights she's at Tinder
and has been there for about eight
months but she's been in the category
for longer than most she'll tell us a
little bit about that too and she's a
go-to on The Today Show on the topic of
relationships and Tech welcome and thank
you for joining us Melissa guys happy
birthday thanks for having me uh I can't
wait for V con I don't know where to
start this is like the best day to like
kick off my uh my Tuesday um thanks for
having me we we love having you
um
so these go so fast Melissa we're going
to get right into it awesome when
actually before we go into the uh power
of community I think you know tinder's
on such a cool Journey from my
perspective and obviously so many of the
people who are watching right now are
very aware of the brand given its
importance in culture just for fun what
are one or two things for the people
that maybe haven't been keeping up with
it or you know aren't looking at the app
every day given where they are in their
life cycle with relationships what's a
what's a thing or two that people don't
realize about Tinder May 9 2023. I love
that question so one is uh an estimated
40 to 50 percent of relationships start
on an app for heterosexual couples for
lgbtq it's as high as 70 to 80 percent
so dating apps are driving a lot of love
a lot of connection and what you may not
know about Tinder is that 40 of people
on Tinder are looking for something
serious we have a like a fun reputation
and we're definitely that but there's so
many people looking for love around the
world on Tinder and by the way vayner's
been an awesome partner of tinders in
getting that story out and and getting
people to look at us in the slightly
well I think you know I think that's an
interesting point when I think about
like marketing and branding and then
just common sense of Life the amount of
people pre-internet pre-apps pre the
cell phone that were in their mind going
to a bar to hook up
you know which is a human thing to do
yeah that ended up meeting the person
that they married for 40 years was very
very very common I would argue you know
obviously you know I would argue a
shocking percentage of the marriages in
the world whether done on the Internet
or in real life at a at a train station
or at a office that that both parties
weren't both in the mindset that like
hey within the next couple months I'd
love to be you know to find my spouse
obviously somewhere obviously there's
plenty of people that both are but I
always thought that Tinder was you know
I actually remember arguing this at
South by Southwest a year or two after
Tinder got really big we used to do
these jam sessions and I actually argued
that Tinder would be the biggest
marriage site in the world and my
argument was that the internet and
Technology all it does is scale what is
naturally happening and I felt that
naturally in life what was happening was
many people were just looking to go on a
date or two or to have you know a casual
relationship but then ended up falling
in love with the person that they were
doing that with by the way you're you're
totally right the uh
so many people like I'm not sure what
I'm looking for I don't know I but I
want to make connection real connection
and real Community starts with that
one-on-one connection right and so
um you are right we are there's a really
interesting study that came out of the
UK uh and researchers I believe it was
the UK researchers went back it's not a
Tinder study and it looked at a really
interesting insight about connection and
that was this is so interesting an
explosion in interracial marriages and
they were trying to understand what is
the cause of this what why did we go
from here to this unbelievable job and
by the way I'm in an interracial
marriage I care deeply about
understanding the drivers of why do we
like we like why do we marry who we
marry what are the what are the cultural
forces that at play there and
the the ingredient to that was Tinder
this explosion and racial marriages
Cinder and then researchers went back
and MIT review covered this just two
months ago is that still the case do we
think tyner's playing that role and uh
and they confirmed again it was Tinder
and part of the picture of that is you
show up on Tinder and first we want to
affirm who you are are you straight gay
short child whatever that is it's
awesome what are you looking for
whatever you're looking for that's great
too you might be looking for tonight you
might be looking for a forever or maybe
you're not sure that's great to you
we're going to have the technology to
support that and and so many people
that's turning into something more in
fact one of the one of the ad spots
that's getting a ton of traction and
some morality on on Tick Tock is a spot
that's like when you match it on Tinder
you thought it was just a one night
stand yeah that turned into two
nightstands
get it love that get it very clever real
quick Marie this is not pre-recorded I
see your question on Facebook we are
live it's it's May 9th 1207 eastern time
all right Melissa let's go into the
concept of this third year anniversary
of marketing for now the power of
community
um you've had a very successful career
as a senior marketer
um you uh you are admired by many of
your contemporaries so I would love to
get your subjective and strategic
opinion on this when you hear the power
of community where does your mind go
within the context of your current role
but even maybe even broader for brands
that you know may be selling batteries
or coffee or sneakers or timeshares yeah
I love that listen I think Community is
such a critical critical ingredient in
our life and we're not even aware of
that when you ask someone wow I saw that
you were at like a you know the high
school basketball game this weekend what
was what was it and oftentimes they'll
say oh well I like the competition of it
all or maybe I went to high school there
it's really what they're getting to is
community is feeling like you're
connected around something and the power
of what that does in our lives and and
it you know it doesn't Gary you have
such an interesting unbelievable career
when you think about the moments that
are really really so positive in your
life that I bet that all comes back to
this idea of community and you know my
my world for over six years is studying
that and working with the most uh famous
and impressive social anthropologists
psychologists uh sociologists
researchers in the world academics
professors people identifying and
discovering new new um new species and
how did they connect and what drove that
and
um the role that Community plays in our
lives is when we don't get enough air
time to so when I was talking to your
team about this subject like oh I get so
jazzed and so moved about that and in my
world of dating you know dating these
things were like people like I hate
dating I hate dating apps it's so hard
by the way yes I'm an executive at the
biggest dating app in the world and I
can say I get it dating is really hard
but when you put yourself out there
you're building that Community by the
way everybody feels that way everybody
feels like Oh I'm a little bit nervous
nobody wants nobody wants rejection
nobody wants rejection but when you do
it it's it's really tough until you find
your person and then it's Roi positive
worth it right
of course
um quick side note as I continue to
interact with the community that is here
Tatiana D is razzing me I uh I wasn't
speaking to Melissa I know she's saying
to me Gary
um uh make sure you know your guest's
name I'm very aware of Melissa's name
what I was saying earlier Tatiana was
Marie was in the comments asking if this
was live and I was answering that so
just to give you a little Clarity on
that uh Melissa parting words as we go
into the next guest what should the
entrepreneurs here that are trying to
build community think about when
building community
that it's that Outreach it's that first
it's that first message I give people
advice all the time and how do I how do
I build connections on Tinder and I say
ask questions so you know I like to give
a little piece of advice is
um if you see whether you see an app
that you like or profile that you like
on Tinder or you see someone that's a
leader in your own community and you
want to learn from them is ask the
questions hey I'm really impressed what
you've done
could I pick your brain for two minutes
on a zoom on a and and get your take on
how you got there and what that is I
think curiosity helps drive that and
Gary I think that's a testament to some
of the things that you've done in
Billings relationships with with
notables from all these industries
around the world is asking those
questions and ask people to share what
they know and and what they've learned
so thanks let me come on and talk about
this I love it I can't I can't wait to
come out to vcon I'm from Indiana I'm a
Hoosier so I was probably the person
most excited I'm like I don't care what
this session is on Gary from another
Indianapolis my family's gonna be there
so I love it thank you for being on have
the best best day have the best day
thanks Gary
we love it all right we're gonna bring
up Melissa Grady Diaz next the global
CMO of Cadillac
and actually a friend of the other
Melissa so we got we got a lot of
Melissa love today I was so excited
we're so happy to have you thank you for
joining us
hey Melissa how are you
doing great how are you good I'm going
to jump back in the comments real quick
one more time yes this is live to the
gentleman who just said I was in Miami
last night that is correct I took a
flight right after the next game you did
see me there I'm very upset but I am in
New York right by Madison Square Garden
which is actually right there uh but we
are here with meliss uh MGD talked to me
about the power of community from the
perspective of you and your incredible
career and then maybe also from the way
Cadillac likes to think about it
I'll start with Cadillac and I think it
really like ties into my career too
um when you look at what community is
and it's just like when you talk about
showing up in culture right there are so
many similarities it's really about
authentic connections and I know the
other Melissa was really talking about
that as well and it's so important and
as we look at where we are in the world
right now it's how people connect and
Cadillac when you one of the things I
love about working on this brand is when
I say I work a Cadillac people love to
jump in and tell me their story yeah
apparently right it's such an amazing
thing and so let me jump to my career
quickly and then I'm going to jump back
to Cadillac when I look at how my career
has really developed and a lot of the
opportunities that have been some of my
favorite jobs they came through a
connection saying let's have a quick
conversation did you hear about this and
there is just this incredible Community
as you're going through your life in
your career that really gets you where
you are and I've one of the things when
people ask me for career advice the
thing that I always say is
never turn down a conversation you just
don't know where it's going to lead to
and the human connections that we build
whether it's in our career our personal
life everything are so important and I
think Melissa said it we don't even
realize how important it is we don't
realize how much we're looking for
connections as people are saying
something we're like oh let me tell you
about my thing with that it becomes so
important and coming back to Cadillac
where it's such a beautiful beautiful
thing with this brand is the stories
about Cadillac and Cadillac's place is
really about the American dream and the
people's manifestation of the American
dream and so when you look at how that
just Builds an immediate Community among
people it's just a it's a it's an
amazing place to to be able to work
do you do you think um and I cut you
know I love what you just said there
like Cadillac
was
and it's like Heyday of heydays every
brain Ebbs and flows
it was such a symbol of the American
dream like there were like in a stunning
amount of humans growing up saying if I
can one day own a Cadillac you know
um do you believe that when a brand
builds such an iconic Community around
such an emotional attachment
um that it's always
resparkable I look at Crocs right I look
at Furby the toy when something is as
big as those things are
if you if you contemporize the the media
the marketing the product there's always
a chance because there's so much emotion
there is that something that you all
think a lot about you know obviously the
Brand's doing great like there's very
few brands that have ever achieved the
status of what Cadillac had in the 50s
and 60s like is it something that is
thought a lot about and like strategized
around and I guess what I'm this
question is going for a lot of the CF
it's a very interesting show we have
tens of thousands of very senior
marketers watch this show and then we
have a lot of people in the private
Equity world that are looking at buying
iconic Brands and then you have a lot of
startups that are looking to create that
moment for the future I was curious
about that from a Cadillac lens
so I a hundred percent and that's where
we start with everything
um we were going through as we're moving
into EV because it's a whole new era for
Cadillac right and it's for automotive
um and when you look at that transition
as we're moving into EV
we said to ourselves we asked this
question which honestly changed
everything in my head and I think for a
lot of people if Cadillac vanished from
the world what would be missing
and if you think about that the answer
is the symbol of the American dream and
an American icon and when you look at
that placement and the emotion that
people have to it that's exactly what
we're tapping into as we move into EVs
and so we're already seeing that story
shift from where we were into today of
when you look at lyric how do I get my
lyric
um you know wow look I mean that vehicle
is absolutely amazing and when you look
at the EVS we have coming so I think
you're right you've got to stay true to
what makes the product what it is and
and once you have that and what makes
the brand what it is because brands are
living things they have a DNA and and
you really can't escape it and to try to
to change it just doesn't really work
and by but by tapping into that and
looking at that there's such a beauty
and as we look to the Future it's really
resonating with people
I like that when you think in your
career as you were coming up the ranks
at what stop or what boss
you think really
nailed this concept of community for you
what product what marketing campaign or
what boss do you think had the biggest
impact on you saying huh this is not
just making pictures and videos and
running media and getting people to buy
a thing this marketing thing there there
is this level of community that is a is
a is a really tangible meaningful part
of the equation
you know I think my biggest first
lessons in community came in my early
days at Motorola
um you really see that with newer
technologies that people get really
passionate about it and
um as as we were
looking at different things as we were
bringing from software to Market you can
either
ignore the community uh you can ignore
the comments you can ignore the haters
honestly which is something that I think
a big lesson for me that I've always
taken forward is listen to what your
biggest detractors are saying who's most
angry
a lot of them are like that because
they're so passionate
talk to them figure out what's going on
figure out how to fix it and that's how
you're going to get people to really get
to that love point and uh there were
there was a lot of opportunity when we
were rolling out some of those softwares
and phones to like really tap in and
learn that lesson and I think it's you
know it's true today I'm constantly on
social communities looking at what
people are saying listening to people
who are messaging me
um and hearing because the there's a
there's a thin line between love and
hate and you've it by understanding
what's frustrating people you can really
like yeah I'm fascinated by P you know
as a you know all my businesses and
obviously as a public figure over the
last 15 years like I I have so much
empathy and compassion and understanding
when people are pushing back or a mad or
or even when people are nasty to me I'm
able to understand that it may mean that
they're not in a good place right now
and they're are upset about something I
said that might have triggered an
emotion a lot of people are taking
things out of context they don't have
the full view of it we live in a world
now of micro information people jump
from a seven second clip to a complete
full observation and belief on someone
that's leading to a lot of people's
anxiety final thought you as a consumer
where do you where do you like to
consume information that lends itself to
maybe bringing you into a community what
are your favorite
consumption forms whether it's
traditional media like print radio
television or modern like a tick tock or
a Spotify or something of that nature
yeah there's there's a few places I
think my my favorite is just
conversation
um I really like to talk to people I
like to understand what they see coming
um and then you know I definitely look
um I'm a secret redditor I go on to
Reddit and see what people are saying
because you see a lot of good real
conversation there and then definitely
in all the like more traditional social
channels as well so
um I I like to end podcasts as well I
love you know sitting here see what
people are saying I think that's another
really really big one for me
this was a lot of fun Melissa thank you
so much I hope you have a great great
spring and summer and see you soon
thank you great to see you thank you
Melissa all right Gary we're super lucky
to have the CEO of Forever 21 up next
Winnie Park she comes with 20 years of
Global Experience in merchandising
marketing digital wholesale retail and
e-commerce across all kinds of
categories so happy to have you here
thanks for joining us Winnie
thank you so much I'm so excited to be
with y'all at Gary happy birthday thank
you three years old I I think we're
walking and maybe even like consuming
harder Foods so we're really happy over
here
let's go right into it when you hear the
power of community give it you know I
love I was thrilled that you were going
to be on you know I grew up as a
retailer first and so much of the way I
think about marketing comes from a lens
of retail
um for you when you when you hear power
of the of community where does that take
you like what what's something worth
sharing what was interesting to you or
maybe even something that you started
off your career not realizing and now is
like a major belief
uh Gary I think Community is actually
everything and I think it's everything
today
um as we look at what it takes to be
meaningful and authentic as a brand
um in the old days of Fashion retail you
could basically tell people what to wear
and which tribe they were going to be
part of and today uh you know customers
and we as people really want Our Brands
to speak culture
and we want them to communicate a sense
of belonging and I think you said
something earlier about an emotional
connection and that is absolutely spot
on and the journey that I've been on
with Forever 21 since I started uh you
know a little over a year ago is tapping
into how do we Unleash the Power of this
brand and go beyond traditional retail
and fast fashion and move into a
dialogue with a customer that is
authentic and creates a sense of
belonging and community
and for us I think that when we go to
the heart of what we've been to Gen X uh
you know Millennials and gen Z we are
really an ally in their Journey for
self-expression fashion as a means to
self-express and so how do we actually
open ourselves up and become that as
opposed to just another place in the
mall where you buy cheap and cheerful
things right right and so that's the
journey we've been on and when I think
about Community
um you know it didn't go far like I
started and I walked into this amazing
community at Forever 21 of creators
designers makers and and honestly true
creatives that brought these ideas to to
me and said and I said let's just make
it happen let's Empower you to do this
last year we had employees who wanted to
celebrate their own Latin Heritage and
they brought together a collection we
did not sanction it we did not say hey
you know go make this happen they came
up with it they came up with a beautiful
collection they created the product they
shot the campaign and they went out and
talked about what it is to be a Creator
and a creative within forever 21. and we
got such a massive response from our
customers because they could also see
themselves reflected in our employees
there was a level there was a level of
authenticity that is just very hard to
replicate in other environments a couple
couple house calling things one it is
not my actual birthday it is marketing
for the now's third birthday of the show
but I really appreciate everyone who's
leaving a comment speaking of which if
you're on LinkedIn Facebook and YouTube
your comments are streaming here heavily
a lot of you have not said hello yet so
a quick one please leave a comment right
now if you're watching the show of where
you physically are in the world city and
state back to Winnie Winnie you came in
about a year ago right yep
let's talk about walking into
challenging environments and trying the
hardest Community I have a lot of
empathy as an operator to the retail
environment that you're walking into the
stat that you know the the state of the
economy right you know what is a leader
at the highest level obviously this show
has a lot of CMOS but we have a high
percentage of CEOs there's a whole
different game that you have to play
than our fellow CMOS here really the
buck stops with you it's all on you
every aspect
how do you how do you look at Community
as you know potentially a trigger to
accelerate some of the vulnerabilities
or opportunities and and do you and and
really even maybe to just go completely
left field because I think a lot of
people get a lot of value out of this
yep when you walk into a new situation
during tough times you're a wartime
general not a peacetime General yes
what's the process to audit the
opportunity
you know I think
um
I think that the the first thing is to
lead with curiosity
and
um and for me it is the Curiosity is
both within the company in terms of what
does our culture value who's sitting
there as our employees what are they
talking about what is relevant to them
and then for us the journey we've been
on is to turn the Paradigm upside down
and say I'm actually at the very bottom
of the pyramid and our customers at the
very top so when you are with a fashion
company you often just focus on the
trends that are out there and instead of
really stepping back and saying what are
our customers saying what do they care
about what are they passionate about and
how do we enter into an authentic
dialogue with them and so for me
um actually at neverwaste a crisis you
know there's that economic headwind
let's really dig in and and turn up our
curiosity and turn up our curiosity
around why our customers ascribe to us
what is their sense of belonging and
community and again for us it was
hitting that that finer Point especially
with our youngest customers out there
gen Z
they really wake up you know rocking Y2K
fashion and they may go to bed rocking
preppy or goth they express themselves
through so many different dimensions and
that really is the language of fashion
that we speak how do we lean into that
how do we go even further and so for us
this year it is how do we build natural
connections with them and quote meet
them where they are end quote that is
what I say all the time meet them where
they are don't superimpose so for us
this year we launched an amazing
partnership for instance with rolling
loud it's the largest hip-hop Festival
in the world and instead of just being
another sponsor right and with another
pop-up I think the question for us was
how do we activate how do we activate
with the founders and how do we do
things that are genuine and fun
um and and interesting so those are some
of the steps that we've taken to really
like bring this
um to uh fruition and leading with
curiosity getting super curious about
customer leaning into their culture and
getting involved
I I you know it's funny I saw the
rolling loud thing I know tarek and the
crew for for a decade from when they
were doing Tiny shows I've always been a
fan and I I think
and you bring up a really interesting
point that is enormous in fashion and I
believe is not being used enough in
other consumer products which is the
power of the collaboration of
communities yes when I think about when
I saw that from afar I was like that's a
nice win for both audiences I think it
gives a cool factor for F21 I think F21
brought a lot of new awareness to
Rolling loud I call those collaborations
of one plus one equals 11.
and so I think that um
I think that that was really um
really well done with two minutes left
are there other community collaborations
you're thinking about and is there a
scenario of too many or is there not
because in reality these are Niche micro
communities and a lot of times they're
not even I mean ninety percent of people
just have that are watching this right
now might have never even heard of
rolling loud so that you can still do
something with great adventure you can
still do something with BMW or Bose
headsets or Hershey's thoughts yeah I
think it goes back Gary to who's your
customer and what do they care about and
it may be micro for the rest of the
world but super important for them and
um so you know just along those lines
we're doing stuff that doesn't
necessarily print money
um to really engage in community uh for
instance our partnership with shop
sitting Roblox
you know for the youngest gen z customer
they start at age nine they spend as
much time in the metaverse as they do in
real life and Roblox has 47 million
players you know and and and people are
active in the community many of which
are super young below the age of 16. so
what do we do we show up where they are
again meet them authentically create a
sense of belonging and for us you know
that opportunity of being in shop
sitting and having creators create their
own Forever 21 has been amazing bringing
bigger Brands like Barbie into that
Community last year was amazing we're
doing it again this year with Barbie
with the collaboration we're doing with
them so this is a clear win-win-win
where one plus one does equal three and
again you you kind of Harvest an
opportunity for the future like if I get
any type of awareness and resonance and
connectivity with a nine-year-old today
think about what they could be for us
tomorrow
I think about it every day Winnie thank
you so much for the value you brought
today have the best week thank you Gary
thank you Lenny
all right Gary now we're going to talk
travel and bring up one of my favorite
Brands virgin but specifically virgin
voyages the cruise line and we have
Nathan Rosenberg who's going to join us
the chief brand officer hey Nathan all
right oh no Ahoy oh
he's been with virgin for a while he was
part of the founding crew for Virgin
voyages I just went on one and I have to
say I was blown away and I'm not part of
the typical audience that would ever
think of going on a cruise so I I give
you my thumbs up but I'll let you guys
take it from the thumbs up I just want
to know where the cake is if it's a
birthday someone's like the marketing
company's birthday like yeah I have a
different question are you wearing this
Miami Heat hat to rub in all the pain I
have yes 100 I'm sorry to take you on
but I just had no choice I know what to
do with that
[Laughter]
usually talk like for the next 10
minutes by myself then if that's how
much it hurts you I really do apologize
so it's lovely to be here thanks for
having me Gary and Andrea uh obviously
incredibly excited to talk to you about
searching voyages and the crazy Journey
we've been on over the last
um number of years like obviously coming
out of a pandemic is not easy when
you're in a cruise line
but I think for us as we're sort of
seeing the world recover and people get
back to travel it is a really really
cool time and we're delivering I hope
experiences people are falling in love
with every single day so that's sort of
the goal we've set ourselves anyway to
try and make sure it's a really great
place and now Andrea loves it and we
have to get you on board at some stage
Gary please leave my hat on even with
your hat on brother very good very good
job a lot of people when I go off screen
when my feelings are hurt in sports
don't know what to do I appreciate your
Gift of Gab let's take advantage of that
here in this meeting
talk about an observation I have so I've
been on I think three maybe four cruises
in my life
in my early days of my wine YouTube show
I actually did something for two to
three thousand of the viewers where we
did a cruise
um for four or five days where we did
wine thing it was just amazing yeah all
four times that I've been on a cruise I
had a very very clear takeaway which was
in that five or seven day window the
humans that were on that ship
immediately
48 hours
24 hours 12 hours became a micro
community in itself for the time that
they were there yeah many of which then
took those serendipitous relationships
different than when you meet someone at
over dinner or at a sporting event
because of the amount of time you're
together yeah something happens in a
week where I know I had dinner actually
recently
with a business friend
whose best friend in the world best
couple's friend was a couple they ran
into at on a cruise became friends and
it came back home oh I remember now one
of the couples is moving to the city of
the other couple this was a business
friend and it was because they met as
friends and the friendship is so
powerful
uh and their kids are older now and
getting out of house they're one of the
couples is moving and I've always just
thought that the cruise environment was
conducive to creating very powerful
communities in the micro in a very quick
time thoughts am I right Am I Wrong what
is what do you see no 150 bajillion
percent basically because there isn't an
opportunity because you literally are
stepping across a bridge and then you're
heading out to sea and there's this
really transformative aspect of being in
a world where you're effectively part of
a larger group of people and you're
looking for connection like our brand
particularly virgin voyages and Andrea
can tell you more about this is
conviviality is the heart of this
connection and Community are the core of
every experience the the best moments
you'll have on board our vessels are
when you come together in smaller and
larger groups to sort of feel that Vibe
basically so we hear stories all the
time about people who have now best
friends or people who've got met someone
they've fallen in love with or someone
who decided to sit up from and someone
else they've fallen in love with because
you have that opportunity Community
going great places and doing great
experiences for it to really sort of
Drive connection
I love that
um what does this audience and this will
be watched over and over and over over
the next six months what is the I think
people can be curious about this because
obviously I think the the your industry
was incredibly affected by the covid
realities and was at the Forefront of
the news in the beginning so I think all
of us have are kind of like Curious I
myself are like what's the state of the
union of the industry
um and and which communities are coming
back first yeah I think the state of the
industry today is actually really strong
like I think compared to where we were
two years ago
um I think all of the cruise lines had a
record q1 basically when it came to
bookings
um travel is back record q1 for bookings
by pre-2019 basically
yeah we literally had our best quarter
we've ever seen uh which is you know
great for us because obviously the thing
is we are a premium product we charge a
little bit more for our experience
because we are an elevated adult
experience
um you know we have lovely restaurants
and boarded and Michelin star curated
there's like [__] you can shake your
phone for champagne on board and things
like that but that notion of um travel
is back and I think now what's happening
when really excitingly is are people
kind of happy to get out there and
they're looking for experiences this is
the thing Gary that's really important
that people go I don't just want a basic
generic holiday I had to deal with so
much rubbish for two years you know
stuck in my home I want to go somewhere
that when I come back from that
experience it feels like I'm Different
I've learned something I've met new
people I've tried things I wouldn't do
and that's what we are very very focused
on in making sure that this is not just
a cruise product and yes Cruisers came
back first because they love the product
but the job at virgin voyages is to say
yes we love Cruisers and we've got
something new and different for you to
try but if you're a non-cruiser here's a
product from a brand that you know and
love that you might have seen with
Virgin Atlantic or you might have tried
and stayed at a virgin hotel where you
might go to space one down Virgin
Galactic but this is it on a ship
basically and all those lovely things
from design to experience to an incred
crew like let's and Andrea can tell you
more about this as well the people on
board the crew who are other people that
actually deliver that experience every
day are where we spend a lot of energy
and time because that's what creates the
connection they know how to bring people
together they know how to create special
moments they can sort of see the vibe
and the energy and create that and
that's what's really important to us is
taking care of our crew so they really
take care of you basically
I love that what uh what's what about
when you program the cruises how much do
you think about micro communities like
the one you know I'm I'm a wine
enthusiast or you know I'm also
competitive so like as many little games
on the there it's possible like you know
movies or things that they like from a
programming standpoint how much is
emerging or established communities a
part of it there's a sort of sense of
both operating at the macro Community
level which is we have this thing we
call the emotional Arc Journey basically
so we know effectively what it's like
when you step on board in the mindset
you have so you think about it you know
you're traveling to Miami you're getting
on the ship basically you've been
through Mia it's a disaster like you're
exhausted you're stressed your bags are
crazy you can't find anything so we know
that first night is about sort of
bringing the energy down so you don't
feel too crazy and then over the next
three to four days we let that sort of
build up and you become a little more
relaxed and chill so that's the
overarching programming thematic and
then we use passion points that we know
that are interesting to our audience
which is absolutely food and which is
why we're sort of famous for food
absolutely brilliant entertainment if
you want to see a Broadway show go to
Broadway but on our ships we've created
entertainment that bring people together
and connect them through music and style
Etc and then ultimately if you just want
to chill there's a well-being stream as
well so we absolutely use those to
stream programming across all the
different passion points adults have
today
what about from a marketing lens
obviously as a chief brand officer what
um what platforms distribution channels
television print
uh digital social
um are you seeing bring you the most
value as an opportunity to tap into
specific communities
um online video is the most powerful
thing because it captures the vibe and
the energy and so what we did in q1 this
year is we sort of there's this sort of
Industry standard where you produce an
ad which is show pictures of ship show
pictures of people having a good time
put supers on it and then kind of run
that out on TV and I think for us
because we know people are sort of
energetic and there's a Vibe on board we
actually use the history of Virgin to
recreate a music video and use Karma
Chameleon which is a song that was
actually from Boy George and Culture
Club that Richard signed 40 years ago
and sort of that brought the Red Thread
through from Virgin in our music history
and then actually showed the vibe like
we weren't there saying here's 25 off
that'll get you a great Cruise was like
no no it's just Epic on board you should
come and experience this so you don't
miss out basically so there is a
traditional approach in something so
we'll do a lot of online video through
the YouTube Etc where we saw incredible
success was on Tick Tock literally the
song got ripped that we recreated
basically with a new artist and
effectively created a dance challenge
and we ended up with almost 100 million
impressions that drove almost higher
conversion and actually engaging with
the brand because we said consideration
is the thing that's most important to
the website it doesn't matter when they
get their outs that we have to sell the
trade was that a big eye-opener for some
of the traditional marketers yeah it was
it was actually even my CEO is going I
don't know what this tikkataka thing is
but it's working we need to do more
brother thank you so much it's always
great to see you take care of yourself
bye bon voyage thank you and thank you
Nathan oh my gosh all right we're back
to retail Gary back to your your
Homeland we've got Sarah zarell who's
going to join us the CMO of Chinese
Laundry I just love Sarah she is truly
gifted at helping organizations scale
and it doesn't matter if it's startups
or Legacy businesses but we're so
excited to have you here Sarah and love
that background
thank you I'm so excited to be here
thank you so much Andreas thank you Gary
it's such an honor to get to chat
Community with you guys today thank you
before we get into it with you Sarah I
just want to give a huge shout out to
the community that's been Super Active
during this episode easy the kids CG
Kathy s Danny Sanderson Maddie Huggins
who's a Vayner uh you know uh family
member uh is in there uh but just really
really keep it going you're dictating
some of my questions thank you for being
a part of this Denise Tyler and more
Sarah I think for a lot of people uh
Chinese Laundry could be something that
might be new for the radar so why don't
we start for a minute I'll give you the
floor and tell everybody what that is
and then we'll go into uh our q a
yeah so Chinese Laundry
um is a leader in the Footwear industry
a dress shoe company is how it started
and now we are
um moving into casuals we actually have
four labels in total in our fashion
house uh Chinese Laundry is the one that
people know the most uh we also have
dirty laundry CL buy laundry and 42 gold
that interestingly enough hits four
different uh demographics so I get the
uh both the honor and challenge of
building four communities for four
different uh types of audiences actually
let's go into that to your point you've
got a portfolio for different
communities four different products but
I assume and I I'm sure you're going to
agree with this what the real challenge
slash opportunity in 2023 is
even within those four different brands
there's probably 20 to 30 meaningful
communities from a psychographic
demographic Financial you know uh gender
race interest graph talk to me about the
Matrix of that and then I have a really
interesting question about
um portfolio management that I think can
help a lot of brand holding companies
out here but but to that point
do you see it as four different
communities or am I right or am I wrong
in that even within the brands like
dirty laundry may have 670 12 meaningful
uh communities that you want to go after
yeah
there are I mean the audience is so vast
and we have so many different skus and
styles of Footwear that will allow our
audience to express themselves every
step of the way uh and so yeah we are
we're targeting
um you know for cl by laundry looking at
like moms flight attendants interior
designers it's a comfort shoe that comes
in wide so it really uh is a shoe that
you can wear uh at the beginning of your
day when you're packing lunches all the
way through your day at your job at the
bank to picking up the kids to coming
back to then going on date night with
your husband they're really like a shoe
for a shoe for life if you will but in
that there's um there's so many
different demographics especially all
throughout the country and the world of
where these shoes would be applicable
because they're good for work or good
for play
um you know dirty laundry is kind of
this like edgier uh was intended to be a
Junior's line but we really see it uh
kind of spanning the demographics and
skewing older as well into people that
just want kind of more of that like
grunge uh kind of feel uh that's a
little bit edgier and that brand in
general were really leaning into uh we
just did a whole Heritage campaign that
explores shoes throughout the ages and
the moments yeah
I was doing that really for Josh
Martinez he just said I do 10 push-ups
every time Gary does air quotes
I just really want him to do 500 of them
so I'll just be doing this while you're
while you're talking and then
TCG bulk Kings has a credible question
how does one pick out the different
cohorts for marketing purposes I'm
having a hard time figuring out how to
understand and select those ideal
personas that's an interesting one for
you especially For You especially giving
your portfolio thoughts
yeah um it's challenging I think that
there's no perfect cohort that you can
pick out and it it's kind of like
throwing spaghetti on the wall like well
for right just for like the example with
cl buy laundry right I'm like okay where
could these shoes be applicable what
what moments does this make sense in and
then what's the profile of that person
and then how can it be replicated to hit
different
um audience and different cohorts and
then we look at you know Chinese Laundry
it's been a brand for 40 years right so
I'm not just targeting a younger
demographic 40 years
40 years yeah I feel like he needs to do
40 push-ups
celebration
the
there's people that are still wearing
their shoes that they are their first
pair of heels and now they only buy
Chinese Laundry they've been buying
Chinese Laundry for the last 40 years
and now they're getting their daughters
and granddaughters into it so that when
it comes to picking out cohorts right
it's a very very wide uh a wide swoft of
people and customers and so then uh you
know to piggyback on what Winnie was
saying it really is like meeting your
customer where they are and creating
meaningful content that they identify
with regardless of age and uh
socioeconomic status and so kind of what
what we're doing uh at sales Brands
which is our parent company is is
leaning into like the moments right the
moments that you have
uh that you need to have shoes on your
feet for
and the feeling that you get right like
the Nostalgia of a first kiss prom in
your like sparkly heels and like how
special is it that your mom also wore
Chinese Laundry it's a problem and what
a beautiful moment you then get to have
with your mom to go buy your first pair
of heels and so building Community
around that and you know I've been I've
been with the company for a year and so
I was really brought in to come in and
Revitalize and uh bring Fresh Life in a
fresh perspective to that point because
I I've been a fan of the Holden Co and
I've looked at you know I I believe that
organic social right now is the most
misunderstood opportunity in all of
marketing because of the tick
tockification of all of marketing and
now organic reach for the first time
ever relevance is now creating consumed
reach which is a profound marketing
you know understanding what you've
you've been brought in
how big do you see the opportunity of
organic social at scale across the seven
or so platforms that are most relevant
of consumer attention as a meaningful
strategy compared to let's say five
years ago
that organic what right
will take those performance dollars and
guarantee that it's going to turn into
an Roi that makes sense well to your
point you're referring to just to help
everybody the iOS 14.5 update which
trackability in that CAC and LTB for
people that sell direct consumer it got
a lot harder and the creative is now a
much bigger variable for Success yeah
and so uh you know for us and I think
for any company that's trying to gain
traction and grow like I'm growing three
of our four labels I didn't have social
platforms uh when I started so I'm in
the process of growing them from scratch
like we just separated
um and gave them all their own website
so we're I'm getting to go in and really
almost treat some of these Brands like a
like a brand new label uh and really
build the direct to Consumer narrative
around them and the community and
um I think it really it really goes back
to that like meeting people where they
are
it's like giving them what they want and
I think that organic is is of Paramount
importance because it's what people are
paying more attention to right there's
been so many ads there's so much noise
what about the consumer insights I think
for us the reason I think we're the
leader in Social marketing is it's not
just we understand the platforms and the
culture we call that pack
it's not only like Tyler said we call it
sock strategic organic content not happy
Tuesday or it's May 9th or yay
um but if the consumer insights that
we're able to extract out of very smart
creative that meets those cohorts is has
that been a part of the thinking or an
opportunity that you see
yeah I mean I love to dig into the data
I think it's really important to see
like what's getting the clicks what
people want I mean I'm seeing that our
are less polished uh content right on
Tick Tock it gets it gets higher
engagement whether that's just at the
office you know goofing off and talking
shoes and doing something silly
oftentimes is better than like a
well-produced you know video and of
course we need those fashion videos in
on our website and in other places but
when we're trying to get organic shares
and we're you know trying to go viral on
different platforms it really is that
like very relatable content where people
can see themselves in those shoes and
um and it feels like something that they
can obtain
Sarah thank you so much for being on
thank you uh before Andrea comes on and
we get to our last guest I want to tell
the community the Lisa Matthews the Dale
Ms the Youssef chevlis the Carol
um the Naveen s uh I need all of you to
comment just like we did earlier on
where you are on your current favorite
brand
I want to see everybody who's watching
right now on LinkedIn Facebook and
YouTube and others current favorite
brand I just want to get some of that
Insight Andrea take us home all right we
got one of my favorite Brands coming up
it's Claire's we have the EVP and CMO
Kristen Patrick joining us I love
Claire's because my husband got his ear
pierced with my daughter when she was
five
they made a little agreement if she
could wait until she was five they were
gonna do it but just one more thing
about Kristen she joined uh Claire's not
too long ago in 2021 but the roster of
brands that you have worked on globally
I'm not even gonna go hit them all but
listen to this you guys PepsiCo Playboy
NBC Universal Disney Revlon Gap and more
and more and more we're so happy to have
you here closing out the show oh thank
you thanks for having me
how are you KP hi you know what we did
work on together was the Mike Tyson
thing too we did that was incredible
um
you know to Andrea's point you've had an
incredible career uh sitting at very
senior levels of some of the biggest
brands in the world uh in many different
sectors what's the connective tissue
across all those different brands when
you think about the framework of this
conversation the power of community
what's a takeaway that is true across
the board and what are some of the
subtle differences when you're in
different sectors or different brands
I think the connective tissue for all of
the businesses that I've worked on is
the importance of cultural culture and
tracking tracking cultural trends like
every single one of those companies
relies on
being first to the market in terms of
Trends entertainment content and sort of
being on the Leading Edge of all of
those and so I'm I'm really attracted to
companies that that do that
um so I think that that would be the the
link to everything and what about the
differences out of all the brands you
worked on whether it's a Playboy or a
Pepsi or currently eclairs what what is
like it what in that Rolodex stands out
is like wow that was an incredibly
passionate micro Community for that
brand and and I'd love to hear because
there might be some double clicking into
that that might be able to help people
yeah
listen any company that I go to I try to
understand
what the consumer is interested in and I
call them lifestyle verticals so it may
be you know Sports was really big for
Pepsi
um uh music was really big for Pepsi you
know for Claire's uh gaming is really
really big for these for for the
generation that we're pursuing
um you know the metaverse is really big
for them so I I classify them by
lifestyle verticals and then we create
strategies
um from a Content perspective around
each of those verticals so it and that
changes from company to company and
consumer segment to Consumer segment
biggest transformation in marketing from
the day you started your career you know
and with all your big Ambitions to where
you sit now
from the form of distribution like you
know obviously we've had such a big
transformation with the growth of the
internet what what do you think we are
in the cycle of that and like what were
the biggest disruptions to that and
because I think that is a huge impact on
building communities if you're if you're
marketing where people can't hear you
you're gonna have a tough time creating
a community if I'm giving a speech in an
empty Hall I have a really tough time
even if it's the best speech I've ever
given of getting any Roi out of that
from a distribution standpoint what have
you seen in your illustrious career like
what's been the biggest changes
I'm going to talk about I think what a
lot of companies are dealing with and
facing
um as it pertains to that distribution
strategy right so it's like
suddenly companies would create you know
three or four television spots a year
they now have to create like thousands
and thousands of pieces of content a day
to put across that distribution channel
it's like you've got YouTube Tick Tock
be real and and a lot of companies are
struggling with that and so you know I
think that what the distribution
pipeline has done
it's it's made
Brands need to become Publishers of
content and that's not their first
business and so you know we dealt with
it at Pepsi we ended up building our own
content Studio it's like there's always
a need for
um agencies but to be able to develop
and create content is a really difficult
task for Brands and businesses because
it's not the first thing that they do
their their products are the first thing
their services
um and then all of a sudden now you're
you're a publisher and you know it also
creates I think a lot of
um issues for brands in that you know if
they put something out and it it it it's
not well received then they have to sort
of deal with that as well so and and a
lot of companies that I talked to are
really struggling with this
what about the role of influencers to
build community you know just thinking
about the businesses you've been on
influencers have been such a
uh important uh change Fame micro Fame
you know obviously you know spokes men
and women have been iconic for
80 years in advertising but now instead
of it being 20 to 50 people that are in
play right for every Kevin Hart
who's you know a modern famous person
who's in a lot of commercials you have
hundreds of thousands of humans who are
making five ten twenty thousand dollars
a year doing influencer work all the way
up to the bigger names that are making
millions you know what do you think
about influencers role in community
building
I think that it's absolutely critical
and I think that you have to really
understand your consumer and again sort
of going back to Lifestyle verticals I
think that you can classify the
influencers that you want to link the
business with based on what they're
interested in so for Claire's for
instance you know we have we're doing
things
um in gaming and
um you know are consumers interested in
design are consumers interested in style
so it's like finding the influencer
within those lifestyle verticals and I I
sort of use that lifestyle vertical
classification to help guide us towards
influencers and then you know I think
that there's tears of influencers
they're sort of the a-level celebrities
that you partner with and then there's
the sort of
um micro influencers that you have to
partner with as well so anytime we we do
a strategy it all starts with that
lifestyle vertical classification
what about parting thoughts here we've
got a minute or two what what do people
what do marketers or entrepreneurs or
Executives here need to know about the
power of community what are they what
give me a subtle point or or something
that's obvious to you that maybe obvious
to others but what's the most obvious
point to you and what's the most subtle
point when I talk the power of community
listen the power of community for me and
and for Claire's right now is is really
about
driving I ideals and movements and that
is really really important to gen Z and
Jen Alpha and so tapping into that
Community for information and knowledge
and leveraging it and it and giving them
your platform to speak on I think is is
what's incredibly incredibly important
and if you don't have sort of the love
and the support of your community I
think today like
I don't know it you're sort of dead in
the water it it that Community creates
the momentum necessary I think to drive
businesses today
Kristen thank you so much thank you
Tim I want to take the last minute here
uh on the show and really just thank
this community our community uh the
emmer inspires the Rodrigo V's the Tommy
bfpv the Joshua Martinez's and on and on
and on Andrea you the team behind you
the Summers the many people that are
three years into this show I remember
the first one was Hardcore code that I
was sitting on a bed
in my room
um and it's been a great journey and
most of all just reading all the
comments reading on the Discord big
shout out to all the V Friends Community
so excited about Becon we're next
Thursday we're kicking off so we're talk
about a community you know just it's so
empowering to be able to bring value to
your community the amount of people over
the last three years that have reached
out and said this show has helped them
like get an interview help them say what
they said in the interview they got them
a marketing job inspired them to get
into marketing uh decide to go into
marketing classes change their career in
marketing this it's been really an
enjoyable journey and just I want to say
thank you uh Andrea for spearheading
this project to all the vaynerx
employees that have helped it and to the
hundreds and hundreds of best marketers
in the world
um it's been really fun to see how much
uh the organization and the community
and the B B2B community and most of all
the people that I'm reading Michelle
McDonald righteous monkey Jonathan like
the our community getting value from
this it's been a very fruitful Journey
yeah I mean this is it's been such a
beautiful experience and we're here to
serve you so if you have ideas and you
want to share things you know keep keep
coming our way because we want to make
sure this is indeed marketing for the
now and things continue to change so
it's a it's a beautiful thing that we
can continue to just share whatever that
we're seeing and and learn a lot from
you as well thanks so much Gary for all
all that you bring to this have a
wonderful wonderful day everybody
vcon.co if you want to go to the
greatest business culture Conference of
all time that is next week vcon dot Co
I'll see a lot of you there next week
thank you team we'll see you next time
see you in Indianapolis and see you in
June everybody